-Hey, guys, it is time
for a brand-new game.
This is "Shreddy or Not."
-♪ Shreddy or not, shreddy
or not, shreddy or not ♪
♪ Shreddy or not, yeah ♪
-Now, here's how this works.
Before the show, we found
two members from our audience
to come join us
down here on stage.
One of them is really good
at guitar, a shredder.
The other has never held
a guitar before in their life.
We have to figure out who's who
by asking them
each one question.
Can we get our guitarists
to the stage, please?
Come on over.
-♪ Shreddy or not, shreddy or
not, shreddy or not, yeah ♪
-I'm just kidding.
How you doing?
Nice to see you, bud.
Thank you for being here.
Okay, contestant number one,
what is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name is Ellis,
and I'm from L.A.
-Okay. Ellis from L.A.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Contestant number two,
what is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name is Hector.
And I'm originally from
New York,
but I live in Jersey now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And that's all I can ask you.
That's all I can ask you.
Now we have to figure out
if you can shred.
Quest, you go first.
You can ask them both
just one question.
For both of them.
-Okay.
Did you master "Eruption"
or "Stairway to Heaven" first?
-"Eruption."
-I have no idea what that is.
[ Laughter ]
-That's interesting.
I feel like that's
a very poker move.
It's gotta be.
-He's trying to throw you
off the trail.
-Yeah, he's trying to throw me
Higgins, it's your turn.
What's your question?
-Well, Quest took mine.
[ Laughter ]
But mullet. You have a mullet.
Hmm.
Alright. Is one of your fingers
super callused?
-I mean, I use my hands a lot,
so I have many calluses
on a lot of my fingers.
-Hmm.
-Okay.
-Alright.
How about you?
-They're kind of soft, so...
No, not really. They're soft.
[ Laughter ]
-Bonus question.
Can you play "Wonderwall"?
-Of course. Who can't play
"Wonderwall," you know?
-I thought he would say,
"maybaaay."
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
Higgins, you asked too many.
Alright.
Okay, I think I know who shreds
and who doesn't,
but my question is
there's a lady who's sure
all that glitters is gold.
-What is that?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sure she's
a wonderful lady.
-Ah!
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
It's time to make our guesses.
Quest, who is the shredder?
What do you think?
Contestant number one
or contestant number two?
-Contestant number two is
trying to throw me off.
I think it's contestant
number two.
-Okay.
Higgbones, what do you think?
-I'm going to go with Quest.
'Cause it's too --
it's too, too much.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
I will say contestant number one
is kind of holding it
like he's ready to just explode
on the world.
-Right. Ready to rock, yeah.
-And so I feel --
But unless he's doing
a really good poker --
-I think he is. I think he is.
He's like Maverick. Not the
movie, but the poker player.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. It's time to find out.
Contestant number one,
show us what you got.
Roots, can we get a beat
and see?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
We got played.
I think we got played
pretty bad.
Contestant number two.
Let's see if shreddy or not.
♪♪
Oh, my God!
Oh!
That's what I'm talking about
right there.
Contestant number two,
you are the winner.
Congratulations.
You get a year subscription
to "RV Lifestyle" magazine
because you're going to be
going on tour.
-That's right.
-And both of you --
Here, you can take it.
You both are going home
with custom
Shreddy Vedder sweatshirts
tonight.
♪♪
Congratulations.
Thank you for playing.
You shred, buddy.
That was awesome.
Oh, my God. Thanks for playing.